[Música]
este domingo culminó Hiroshima la Cumbre
de los líderes del g7 el evento contó
con la participación del presidente
ucraniano voladimir zelenski por
supuesto durante el encuentro Se abordó
la guerra en Ucrania pero también la
creciente preocupación sobre la
influencia de China a lo que Moscú y
Beijing respondieron con firmeza para
hablar de este tema saludamos en San
Juan Puerto Rico al doctor layos
sastieles analista de relaciones
internacionales y estudios estratégicos
de fuerzas terrestres navales aéreas y
espaciales rusas y además es profesor
adjunto de la Universidad Interamericana
de Puerto Rico señor sazz di Bienvenido
a directo América Buenos días Gracias
Cuál es la evaluación general sobre esta
Cumbre del g7 que hace usted qué mensaje
cree que envía este encuentro
bueno ciertamente da la impresión un
mensaje de unidad entre los miembros del
grupo de los siete y claro eso pues
También incluye los países de la Unión
Europea en general con alguna que otra
excepción pero países de la Unión
Europea países de la organización del
tratado del Atlántico Norte otan que
pues principales miembros están
representados en el grupo Los siete en
el caso de la otan ya saben Estados
Unidos Canadá Reino Unido Alemania
Francia Italia en el caso de la Unión
Europea pues no está el Reino Unido pero
Francia Italia y Alemania y también está
representada la Unión Europea por la
presidenta de la comisión por ejemplo
Así que esto por un lado estos países
occidentales en conjunción con Pues el
Japón miembro del grupo de los siete
asiáticos y pues también se puede
considerar en ese grupo yo diría a Corea
del Sur y bueno aunque oficialmente no
lo sea también Taiwán
aunque como no es reconocido como país
soberano y porque solo se reconoce a la
china hay una sola china pero es un
socio vamos a decir preferente de ese
grupo de los siete aunque no se lo
anuncie con bombo y platillo Así que
estaríamos hablando diría yo de una
especie de
no digo coalición pero
una agrupación que yo le llamaría del
hemisferio norte
como decir
versus Sur global Entonces está ese
bloque del hemisferio norte que se
enfrenta a la amenaza doble la real por
la guerra no de Rusia la Guerra de
Ucrania y la otra que sería la china
por cuestiones comerciales como por las
ambiciones sobre Taiwán y el mar de la
china meridional vamos a ir abordando
estos dos temas por ejemplo según dijo
el presidente Luis Ignacio Silva quien
hizo parte de este encuentro la guerra
en Ucrania es un tema que no debe
abordarse en el g7 sino en la ONU Qué
opinión le merece esto
Bueno
sí Hasta cierto punto pero realmente al
final la Guerra de Ucrania se ha de
resolver Pues por los principales
actores involucrados y ahí tenemos a
Rusia pero si Rusia no quiere
ceder ante sus ambiciones territoriales
imperiales sobre Ucrania y Ucrania no va
a abandonar sus derechos a su territorio
soberano ocupado ilegalmente por Rusia
realmente pues las Naciones Unidas no
pueden lograr mucho al respecto bien
otro tema del que se habló allí fue de
China por ejemplo durante la Cumbre se
dijo o se llevó un consenso sobre
eliminar el riesgo sin desacoplarse de
China cómo se puede interpretar esto
Bueno sería la cuestión de Me parece que
el intento sería
sin desconectarse de las relaciones
económicas comerciales de la
colaboración en aspectos pues
científicos tecnológicos con la china
pero guardando también manteniendo la
guardia con respecto a problemas como el
tema del espionaje como tiktok etcétera
o Huawei no con las tecnologías g5 que
no se cierra las puertas con la China y
al fin al cabo es un importantísimo
socio comercial de Estados Unidos de la
Unión Europea pero al mismo tiempo claro
no no desconectarse de la china pero
manteniendo la guardia con respecto Pues
a las sonadas porque así aparece
reportado en la Prezi por declaraciones
del gobierno chino amenazas a Taiwán
amenazas de guerra y o la cuestión del
mar de la china meridional de la libre
navegación Y eso de desacoplar de no
desacoplarse la china pues ya ven que
Alemania decidió venderle creo que es
una cuarta parte no no una tercera una
cuarta parte de las acciones del puerto
de Hamburgo si bien recuerdo a una
empresa a la empresa china que
administra pues eh que está presente por
el comercio marítimo de la china con
Alemania y está presente en Hamburgo
pues eh No negarle la posesión de una
cuarta parte se decía que no debía de
ser eso incluso por el peligro de que la
china lo puede usar como espionaje y el
canciller Alemán consultó con la
presidenta de la comisión Ella habló de
eso que no hay que desacoplarse la china
Así que se le permitió la compra creo
que esa cuarta parte de las acciones o
sea tener una relación no cortar
completamente
Pero me imagino que mantener la guardia
También usted lo mencionaba china son
importantes socio para varios países de
occidente pero ya beijina reaccionado a
esta declaración que se dio durante el
g7 puede que esto vaya a tener un
impacto en las relaciones comerciales
entre China y occidente muy brevemente
por favor
bueno
en el sentido Por ejemplo de los
Microchips no de no depender tanto de la
china en el sentido de tierras raras de
no depender tanto de la China y Buscar
otras fuentes minerales Eh sí pero al
mismo tiempo china necesita del comercio
con occidente jamás el brix por ejemplo
podría reemplazar al grupo de los siete
y en ese sentido Hay que decir que el
brix es un actor importante las
relaciones internacionales pero jamás
podrá suplantar al grupo Los siete y la
china tampoco podrá reemplazar el dólar
como tanto se habla no de que bueno a
reemplazar el dólar No porque no olviden
la mayor parte de las reservas tan solo
ese ejemplo de la china son en dólares
Mira la usas y analistas relaciones
internacionales Gracias por acompañarnos
en este espacio de directo América con
el análisis
Gracias por invitarme Y ustedes
televidentes de esta manera termina Este
primer bloque de directo América Gracias
por acompañarnos pero no se desconecten
porque ya regresamos
[Música]